>>> AS THE FORMER PRESIDENT
FACES MORE LEGAL FIGHTS AND
CONSIDERS ANOTHER RUN FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE IN 2024, HE APPEARS
TO BE PUBLICLY EMBRACING THE
CULT OF Q, THE CULT OF QANON,
THAT HAS BEEN AROUND FOR
CENTURIES BUT WITH MODERN
TWISTS.
DONIE O'SULLIVAN HAS A CLOSER
LOOK TONIGHT ABOUT THE
IMPLICATIONS.
>> I DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT THE
MOVEMENT OTHER THAN I UNDERSTAND
THEY LIKE ME VERY MUCH.
>> Reporter: THIS ILLUSTRATED
MEME FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
RESHARED LAST WEEK WITH QANON
SLOGANS AND A Q ON HIS LAPEL IS
A BRAZEN ENDORSEMENT OF THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
>> A GUY WEARING A Q PIN, STORM
IS COMING.
>> Reporter: HOSTS ON THIS RADIO
SHOW CELEBRATING.
>> THAT IS THE REASON YOU ARE
ALL HERE.
YOU ALL KNOW THE TRUTH.
YOU KNOW WHO DONALD TRUMP REALLY
IS.
YOU KNOW WHO THE FIGHT IS ABOUT
AND WHO THE PLAYERS ARE THAT
WANT TO DESTROY OUR COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: ON TRUMP'S SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORM, QANON FOLLOWERS
SAW THE POST AS A CLEAR SIGN HE
IS WITH THEM AND WITH QANON.
ONE POST READ THAT ANY SIGN IS
IN MAJOR DENIAL.
ANOTHER READ, DONALD TRUMP HAS
OVER 4 MILLION FOLLOWERS YET HE
SEEKS OUT Q PEOPLE TO REACH OUT.
>> WHAT WE'VE SEEN RECENTLY FROM
TRUMP IS DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST.
PRIOR TO THIS, HE WOULD SAY HE'S
HEARD OF THESE QANON PEOPLE, HE
BELIEVES THEM TO BE GREAT
PATRIOTS.
NOW THE MESSAGE IS DIRECTLY
ONE-TO-ONE.
IT'S NO LONGER AMBIGUOUS.
>> CERTAINLY WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE QANON PHENOMENON.
>> Reporter: THE FBI HAS WARNED
OF THE DANGERS OF QANON AND ITS
POTENTIAL TO INSPIRE VIOLENCE.
>> WHAT WE HAVE IS A FORMER
PRESIDENT, POTENTIAL CANDIDATE
FOR THE PRESIDENCY OF THE UNITED
STATES LEGITIMIZING, IN ESSENCE
A CULT.
>> Reporter: QANON HAS BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH BIZARRE CLAIMS
ABOUT CHILD SACRIFICE, BUT THE
SLOGANS AND SYMBOLS OF QANON
HAVE BECOME INTERTWINED THE
TRUMP'S LIES ABOUT A STOLEN
ELECTION.
>> I SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE WEARING
QANON T-SHIRTS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THEY'RE ALL
NECESSARILY VIOLENT.
>> IT DOES NOT.
THAT'S THE MOS